hi my name is reto Meier
I'm the tech lead for Google's Android
developer relations team every time your
app initiates a data connection no
matter how much data it transfers you
cause a typical 3G wireless radio to
continue drawing power for upwards of 20
seconds this efficient data transfers
devbyte we'll look at how you can use
tools like sync adapters to batch and
bundle your data transfers effectively
phase-shifting them to produce a highly
efficient defragmented network traffic
profile like this one the underlying
philosophy is to reduce the number of
transfer sessions by designing for a
small number of large downloads we can
do that by batching up all of our delay
tolerant transfers and bundling them
together with time-sensitive ones
potentially even pre-empting planned
future transfers for example if your app
uses analytics rather than uploading
data as it's collected you can bundle
the results together queuing them for
later upload when your app performs a
time-sensitive download similarly any
time-sensitive transfers should also pre
amp updates or prefetching scheduled to
occur in the near future
in each case you're attempting to
mitigate the cost of the transfer either
by either with a delay tolerant upload
or a planned future download by having
them key back on the time-sensitive ones
so now let's look at some techniques
that you can use to implement these best
practices you can start by creating a
batch queue to offset those delay
tolerant uploads this code snippet shows
a simple queue to which you can add
either upload or download transfers that
should occur in the future then whenever
you execute a time-sensitive on-demand
download or the next periodic update or
prefetch is initiated you can also
execute the transfers stored in your
queue this simple approach can be
effective but implemented naively if it
introduces the risk of transfers being
lost if your app is closed before the
queue is cleared that's fine if your
queue transfers are only relevant to the
current session but for things like
analytics or user created data you want
to make sure that you never lose
anything the best solution is using a
content provider this skeleton
implementation shows the basic query
insert delete and update methods that
you would need to implement a content
provider can be backed by any
stall but most commonly in SQLite
database now rather than implementing a
batch queue you can insert data into
your content provider and then when your
next transfer begins query it for
pending transfers and remove
successfully transmitted data from that
queue in this example I'm querying for
queue check-ins sending them to a server
and removing the successfully completed
ones from the queue I still need to
technique to bundle these delay tolerant
transfers with the time-sensitive ones
or possibly also reschedule those
transfers periodically to ensure that
they do eventually happen most simply I
can revisit the earlier approach of
creating a series of methods to execute
each transfer and then ensure that each
calls the other a much neater
alternative is to use a sync adapter
that's going to execute each of our
transfers within its own perform sync
method it's important to note that each
of the methods called should contain its
own logic for determining whether or not
it should actually perform an update
potentially skipping transfer sessions
if the radio hasn't already been
activated by a higher priority method
using a sync adapter to manage your
transfers has a number of advantages
including making it easy to centralize
all your taps data transfers in one
place so they all run at the same time
your data transfers can also be
scheduled with transfers from other apps
or working towards the goal of reducing
the number of times the system has to
switch on the radio sync adapter also
implements data transfer best practices
for you including checking for network
connectivity retrying downloads when
connectivity returns and automated
batching and time shifting on requests
that occur within the same time window
creating a sync adapter is actually
pretty straightforward start by
extending the abstract thread of the
sync adapter class and implementing your
own data transfer code within the on
perform sync handler as you can see here
when executed the sync adapter will
spawn a thread to invoke sync operation
so you don't need to worry about moving
your code into a background thread and
similarly multiple executions will be
rejected so you can write your transfer
code knowing that it won't be running
concurrently with itself in order to run
the sync adapter must be bound to a
service so you also need to create a
service that instantiate your sync
adapter and binds to it sync adapters
were originally designed to support
synchronization of a content provider
associated with an account for example
Gmail now as a result you need you also
need to associate each syncadapter with
an account type and a content provider
Authority if you don't use accounts for
your application you can create your own
mock account by extending the abstract
account authenticator in this
boilerplate you can you'll notice that
I'm overriding the Add Account method
here you would typically ask the user to
enter their authentication details for
your service but instead you can just
create a new stub account and explicitly
add it to the account manager take
particular note of the account type you
specify like the sync adapter the
account authenticator also needs a
service from which to run so create a
new service that binds to your
implementation then create a metadata
file for your account authenticator note
in particular the account type which
much must match the one which you
provided earlier in your implementation
the sync adapter also requires a content
provider as we described earlier a comp
content provider is an effective and
efficient way to store the data that
you're planning to transfer but if you
prefer not to use one you can create a
stubbed-out implementation like this
next create the metadata file for the
sync adapter that will be used to
associate a content provider and account
type with it no but here I'm marking the
sync adapter as not used visible so
users won't be able to disable syncing
from their global settings finally add
the new services and content providers
to the application manifest associating
the sync adapter metadata with the sync
adapter service the account
authenticator metadata with the account
authenticator service with your sync
adapter complete you can now start
thinking about how to trigger your
synchronization so you can configure
your sync adapter to run when server
data changes when the data on the device
changes when the framework sends a
network tickle or at predetermined
intervals or even on demand to be as
efficient as possible it's best practice
to rely primarily on server initiated
synchronizations and where possible
avoid starting syncs as the direct
result of the user action basically try
and eliminate the refresh button the
hardest part of the process is
determining which transfers are delay
tolerant and which will require a sync
to be initiated now this flow chart
gives an indication of the most common
initiators for possible syncs and I'll
go through each flow now demonstrating
how to trigger a sync adapter in each
case
the best approach is to rely on server
pings notifying your app that there is
new data to download using Google Cloud
messaging which I'll explore in more
detail in another dev byte you can
notify each installed instance of your
app that it needs to sync with the
server simply listen for an incoming GCM
message notifying you of new data
becoming available and call request sync
specifying the appropriate account and
authority this eliminates the need for
any client-side polling while
maintaining constantly up-to-date client
data conversely you may want to
synchronize changes on the client side
to the cloud and this could be anything
from analytics data to new email so you
want to be careful when deciding which
changes are sufficient to initiate an
actual transfer if you're using content
providers you can configure your sync
adapter to trigger whenever the content
provider changes by setting the supports
uploading attribute to true which
happens to be the default now when this
is set and upload only sync will be
requested whenever your content provider
executes a notify change call with the
sync to network parameter set to true as
shown yeah now within the on perform
sync handler you can detect these upload
only syncs by examining the sync extras
upload extra this can be useful if you
want to rate limit client initiated
transfers you can also configure your
sync adapter to sync
whenever the platform opens a connection
to keep the tcp/ip connection used for
things like Google Cloud messaging alive
by setting it to sync automatically now
this approach assures that your app is
regularly updated without having to
schedule your own client-side polling
now that said the frequency of network
tickles can lead to a large number of
transfers so this should only be enabled
when your app is in the foreground and
even then you may want to artificially
lower the frequency of syncs within your
on perform sync method now if you want
to perform regular thanks at a known
frequency you can use the add periodic
sync method well you can set any
frequency this approach is more
typically used to ensure at least one
sync happens every 12 to 24 hours
when the app isn't already running
typically with client and server changes
initiating most of those updates
particularly when the app is in the
foreground now finally if you need to
initiate a time-sensitive transfer
either when the app launches when the
use of browsers are something that
you've not
Fetchit or just a prefetch additional
data you can call request sink in cases
where an update must occur immediately
in order to avoid impacting the user
experience you can force a manual
expedited sync by setting the manual and
expedited flags within the settings
bundle these settings will ignore any
back offs and sync settings that might
delay the sync and attempt to execute it
immediately instead now you can find all
the details for creating and using sync
adapters in this Android training class
so having learned how to perform our
updates efficiently other devbytes will
look at ways to adjust our update
frequency reducing data payload sizes
and using a Google Cloud messaging in
more detail